der starke Mann im Kreml seit über zwei
Jahrzehnten ist Vladimir Putin der
unangefochtene Herrscher Russlands einer
mit dem immer zu rechnen ist und der den
Westen im ukraine-krieg herausfordert
wie nie zuvor
dann am 24 Juni 2023 geschieht das
Undenkbare Wladimir Putin sieht sich von
seinem eigenen Kämpfern bedroht
angeführt von söldnerchef Jewgeni
prikosin
gepanzerte Fahrzeuge auf dem Weg nach
Moskau
das ist kein Putsch es ist ein Marsch
der Gerechtigkeit ich warne jede wir
sind unzerstörbar der Präsident
herausgefordert von seinem früheren Koch
ist das der Anfang vom Ende der Ära
Putin
Zeit ist vorbei die Uhr tickt schneller
und schneller
laufen die Geschäfte in Kreml weiter wie
gewohnt
80% der Menschen unterstützen Putin
immer noch es hat sich nichts geändert
dieser Film rekonstruiert den Tag der
die Welt den atemhielt und untersucht
wie tragfähig die Fundamente von Putins
macht noch sind
24 Juni 2023
Ausnahmezustand in Russland es gibt
Berichte über revoltierende seltener der
Anführer der Wagner Sydney Evgeny
pregorian sagt seine Kämpfer würden sich
nicht ergeben
Bilder von Kämpfern der Gruppe Wagner in
der südrussischen Millionenstadt
hundertfach gefilmt und verbreitet in
den sozialen Medien
[Musik]
an diesem 24 Juni ist das System Putin
zum ersten Mal richtig und vor aller
unserer Augen vor den Augen der
Weltöffentlichkeit durchgeschüttelt
worden
in Kreml herrscht Alarmstimmung es ist
ein Geruch den man nie vergisst der
Geruch der Angst man konnte Putins Angst
riechen
sieht sich zu einer öffentlichen
Reaktion benötigt
wir werden sowohl unser Volk als auch
unseren Staat vor allem Bedrohungen
beschützen auch vor internem Fahrrad
und hier haben wir es tatsächlich mit
Fahrrad zu tun
ein paar Stunden lang scheint alles
möglich selbst der Sturz des Präsidenten
viele der Söldner sind ehemalige
Soldaten die Gruppe Wagner eine Gründung
des Geheimdienstes
kann sich Putin auf eine der wichtigsten
Säulen seiner Herrschaft noch verlassen
[Musik]
Moskau 2019 das jährliche Hochamt der
russischen Streitkräfte die
Militärparade anlässlich des Sieges über
Nazi Deutschland
seit 2008 ist viel Geld in die Armee
geflossen sie gilt als hochgerüstet und
Kampf erprobt
ausgestattet mit modernen Panzern
luftabwehrsystemen
Interkontinentalraketen
russland hatte in den letzten zwei
Jahrzehnten immer wieder seine
Streitkräfte modernisiert und auch ein
Stück weit reformiert reorganisiert
restrukturiert und das kennen wir auch
aus den westlichen Streitkräften ist
allein schon ein schwieriges Unterfangen
Putin braucht eine schlagkräftige Armee
doch er misst traut den Militär zum
Verteidigungsminister macht er einen
alten Freund Sergej schweigu der hat
sich als Minister für Katastrophenschutz
bewährt war aber nie Berufssoldat
ist wirklich eine interessante
Persönlichkeit das letzte Überbleibsel
aus der jelziniere er war in den 90er
Jahren eine große Figur in Russland ist
jetzt Verteidigungsminister und ein Jagd
und angelkumpel
putinsingen es gibt wahrscheinlich
niemanden in der russischen Regierung
der putinär steht
als Verteidigungsminister hat es schon
mit einem alten Problem zu tun der weit
verbreiteten Korruption
wir haben das als ein Phänomen schon
seit der 90er Jahren das gerade mehr
militären Mittel also mehr Finanzmittel
fürs Militär abgezwackt werden so dass
man offensichtlich auch vieles nur auf
dem Papier hatte
was einsatzbereiter Fahrzeuge die gut
gewartet kurz gut gepflegt und gute
repariert waren aber auch was den
Ausbildungsstand der Soldaten anbelangt
so dass hier hochgradig Korruption was
er in Russland nicht ein Fehler im
System sondern de facto das System ist
natürlich auch in den Streitkräften eine
große Rolle spielen
Putin weiß um die korruptionsprobleme
das ganze Ausmaß kommt erst mit dem
Ukraine Krieg ans Licht
[Applaus]
am 24 Februar 2022 befiehlt der
Präsident den Angriff auf das
Nachbarland auch internationale
Beobachter erwarten einen schnellen
russischen Sieg ich bin der Auffassung
des Präsident Putin ganz sicherlich von
der Annahme ausging würde innerhalb
kürzester Zeit mit einer überraschungs
Militäroffensive die Regierung in Kiew
beseitigen können am besten umlegen
töten können und sich dann in den
östlichen und südöstlichen Teil der
Ukraine dauerhaft niederlassen um mit
dieser Präsenz am Ende des Tages die
strategischen Geschicke und die Zukunft
der Ukraine mitbestimmen zu können doch
der geplante Blitzangriff verwandelt
sich in einen Zellen Krieg auf den die
russische Armeen nicht vorbereitet ist
die Truppen sind schlecht ausgebildet
schlecht ausgerüstet und schlecht
organisiert
die ukrainische Armee war auf diesen
Krieg vorbereitet genau wie die
ukrainische Bevölkerung die nie zuvor so
geeint war
warum waren die Russen so schwach wegen
der Korruption
als die Erfolge ausbleiben wird die
russische Kriegsführung zunehmend brutal
umkehren war keine Option für ihn also
hat er sich daran gemacht wirklich mit
dem gesamten Instrumentarium
militärische Art dass er besitzt zur
Versuchung diese Ukraine zu vernichten
um dann letztendlich eine ja irgendwie
geartete Rest Ukraine vielleicht noch
neben sich zu Duden
neben der regulären Armee hat Putin über
viele Jahre private Militäreinheiten
entstehen lassen
hochgerüstet mit staatlichen Mitteln
Prinzip
das Gesetz von Diktaturen dass in hohem
Maße gestreut wird mehrere Geheimdienste
mehrere militärische ist Strukturen
Auflösung von klaren institutionellen
Regelungen um auf diese Weise zu
verhindern dass ich
aus dem Kreis der bewaffneten Macht so
etwas wie ein Kronprinz entwickelt der
dann gegebenenfalls wirklich nach der
Macht greifen kann
gegenüber der regulären Armee haben
Söldner aus Sicht des Kreml
entscheidende Vorteile
erstens kann man ihre Anwesenheit
leugnen da es sich nicht um die
offizielle russische Armee handelt und
zweitens hatte man vor sie für
Operationen einzusetzen bei denen es zu
Menschenrechtsverletzungen kommt bis hin
zu Kriegsverbrechen
Putins berüchtigte Schattenarmee ist die
Gruppe Wagner vor allem in Afrika
unterstützt sie schwache Regierungen und
erhält dafür Zugang zu Rohstoffen
[Musik]
die Gruppe Wagner hilft der korrupten
Elite Geld zu verdienen ich nehme an in
erster Linie profitiert Putin persönlich
um eine Privatarmee die nicht dem
Verteidigungsministerium sondern dem
Geheimdienst unterstellt ist sie wickelt
für Wladimir Putin weltweit Geschäfte ab
in der Ukraine liefern die Truppen von
wagnerchef prigogin das was Putin
dringend
immer sehr nah gestanden
wegen seiner kriminellen Vergangenheit
war aber nie Teil davon
selbst Geschäfte im großen Stil gemacht
hat hatte immer nur den Interessen von
Putins Elite gedient
damit die immer größer und reicher
wirdner Truppe ist Verteidigungsminister
Scholl GU ein Dorn im Auge die beiden
Männer sind nicht nur Konkurrenten
sondern seit langem persönlich
verfeindet
gleich nach Kriegsbeginn wurde Gregor
Jin von Putin selbst prominent den Zähne
gesetzt weil Putin nicht wollte dass die
Armee zu einflussreich wird
[Musik]
er wollte nicht dass Sergej der ein sehr
beliebter Verteidigungsminister und
wahrscheinlich der zweitbeliebteste
Politiker des Landes ist noch beliebter
wird
[Musik]
mit Propaganda Videos extremer
Brutalität und militärischen Erfolgen
macht sich die seltene Armee einen Namen
ihren größten Sieg erringt die Truppe im
Mai 2023
mit der Einnahme von bachmut nach
monatelangen Kämpfen ist die Stadt fast
vollständig zerstört
[Musik]
also bachmut ist für Wagner ein
Einsatzort gewesen wo man zeigen wollte
dass man Erfolge einfahren kann die die
russischen regulären Truppen nicht
einfahren konnten dazu war prigorchin
bereit eine irrsinnige Menge an Personen
wirklich zu opfern er sagt er selbst er
spricht vom Fleischwolf bachmut also das
ist alleine schon
für uns schwer vorstellbar so ein Wort
zu benutzen er wollte damit zeigen dass
er die bessere Armee ist als die
Verteidigungsministeriums angeht es ist
ins große Stunde auch wenn der Sieg vor
allem ein symbolischer ist die Stadt hat
keine strategische Bedeutung
erzielte Erfolge die schulgur und nicht
vorweisen konnten
nutzt seine Popularität um die
Militärführung und seinen
intimfeindscheu öffentlich anzuklagen
haben 70% zu wenig Munition
auf wo verdammt noch mal nicht die
Munition diejenigen vor allem die
Kontakt haben zu der militärischen
Geschehen an der Front wissen und sehen
es läuft schlecht teilweise katastrophal
mit hohen Verlusten mit logistischen
Problemen fehlende Koordinierung
zwischen unterschiedlichen
Truppengattungen und so weiter und so
fort und holen sie ab Putin lässt ihn
gewähren
das wurde von Putin sehr geschätzt denn
er brauchte diesen pr-er Erfolg
eine Person wie Gregor Gin um die
militärische Stärke den sogenannten
militärischen Geist Russlands zu zeigen
aber auch eine Art Gegengewicht zu
scheuburg
er ist als privatin immer beliebter wird
und immer ungehemmter gegen die
Militärführung wettert entzieht ihm
Putin seine Kunst künftig sollen alle
Privatarmeen den
Verteidigungsministerium unterstehen
im Grunde genommen hat sich die
Beziehung zwischen Wladimir Putin und
prigorchin im letzten halben Jahr so
entwickelt dass eine solche Situation
immer wahrscheinlicher wurde
Putin ging nicht mehr ans Telefon er
trat sich nicht mit Jeff geny
pregorschin und entfernte auch dessen
Vertreter aus dem Führungskommando
am 29 April gibt brigorge in einem
russischen militärblogger ein
denkwürdiges Interview
du kriegst nicht mehr Munition weil du
deine Waffen gegen Moskau richten den
krimmelstürmen könntest diese Art von
Sorgen wie unbegründet sind die ein
Maßstab Moskau das ist ein interessanter
Gedanke aber wir haben noch nicht
darüber nachgedacht
8 Wochen später wird rigor in die Idee
umsetzen
aufstand und Krieg haben der Welt die
Grenzen von Putins Militär macht vor
Augen geführt die Voraussetzungen dafür
hat der Herr im Kreml selbst geschaffen
im Januar habe ich einen Artikel darüber
geschrieben dass der Bürgerkrieg in
Russland längst begonnen hat und ich
denke dass jeder weiß dass ein Land mit
großen Privatarmeen die von Gangstern
geführt werden auf Probleme zusteuert
und das ist genau das was wir jetzt
beobachten können
am Abend des 23 juni schickt prigage in
Einheiten von luhansk ins südrussische
Roßdorf
angeblich wurden seine Truppen zuvor von
der russischen Armee beschossen
sei gut ist einfach feige aus Rostow
abgehauen damit er nicht erklären muss
warum er mit Hubschraubern unsere Leute
vernichten wollte
wir werden diese Kreaturen
weitgehend widerstandslos übernehmen die
Söldner die Stadt und das dortige
Kommandozentrum der regulären russischen
Streitkräfte
hat erkannt dass dies seine Chance ist
auf irgendeine Art die Kontrolle über
das Verteidigungsministerium zu
übernehmen ich bin mir fast sicher dass
die Generäle vom Militär Geheimdienst
nichts dagegen gehabt hätte
das Hauptquartier des südlichen
militärbezirks besetzt hatte da war die
Reaktion von General alexef auf der
Veranda bemerkenswert
wir wollen den generalstaatschef und
scheu holen
nehmt sie mit vorher gehen wir nicht
erst um 10 Uhr vormittags kommt ein
Signal aus dem krenne Putin spricht von
aufstand und Verrat ohne pregorge
namentlich zu nennen
wie bei mir Ehrgeiz und persönliche
Interessen haben zu Verrat geführt
Verrat an unserem Land Verrat an unserem
Volk und an der Sache für die die Wagner
Soldaten an der Seite mit unseren
Einheiten gekämpft haben und gestorben
sind
Militärfahrzeuge zu sehen die Anti
terror-
eine irrwitzige Situation die Putin
persönlich aber auch sein lange
gepflegtes Image schwer erschüttert
[Musik]
die Inszenierung der Macht Putin
beherrscht sie wie kein zweiter
seine Versprechen lauten Sicherheit und
der Aufstieg zu alter Größe
sein images also das eines Politikers
der Russland eine neue Epoche schenken
möchte und das ist das was er gerade
naja ein Stück weit auch bedroht sieht
mit gutem Grund würde ich sagen aber
lange Jahre hat das funktioniert
im Kaukasus fordern islamische Kämpfer
den russischen Staat heraus
tschetschenische Rebellen die auch
hinter einem verheerenden Terroranschlag
in Moskau stecken sollen
putin ist damals noch weitgehend
unbekannt die Anschläge sind seine
Chance sich vor den bevorstehenden
Wahlen zu profilieren
wir werden die Terroristen überall hin
verfolgen notfalls machen wir Sie auch
auf dem Scheißhaus kalt sonst noch
Fragen
putin ist kommissarischer Präsident als
er einen brutalen Vernichtungskrieg
gegen Tschetschenien beginnt
nachdem sich das Land sehen ein junger
trinkt nicht kommt aus den
Sicherheitsdiensten aus den
Geheimdiensten hat also ein Gefühl dafür
dass die russische Öffentlichkeit nach
Sicherheit gerade zuletzt und so baut er
seine Image auf zunächst als Garant von
einer neuen Epoche in der Russland
sicher sein wird nach innen da gibt sich
das Image eines damals virenen jungen
starken Mannes Führers an der Spitze des
Landes der dieses Land nach innen und
außen wieder stark macht und das ist
sozusagen der Hauptpunkt den er
eigentlich so als
legitimationsresse hat
ein Mann wie in die Wähler lieben
2000 wird Putin Präsident
und dem neuen scheint vieles zu gelingen
es geht aufwärts vor allem mit der
Wirtschaft the moment
wurde war die russische Wirtschaft am
Boden
aber wie der zuverlässig wollte begann
der Ölpreis genau im Jahr 1999 zu
steigen
das war als Putin zum ersten Mal
Ministerpräsident wurde für ihn ein
Glücksfall
für Leute aus seinem inneren Kreis war
Putin ein Politiker der immer Glück
hatte fast ohne etwas dafür tun zu
müssen
im Laufe der Jahre erschafft Putin ein
System in dem alles auf ihn
zugeschnitten ist er ist Präsident und
auch mal Ministerpräsident er verlängert
seine Amtszeit oder ändert die
Verfassung um weiter an der Macht zu
bleiben
seine Gegner verfolgt er mit aller
härter auch das gehört zu Putins Image
[Applaus]
im August 2020 trifft es den
Oppositionspolitiker Alex er bricht auf
einem russischen Inlandsflug zusammen
vergiftet mit dem nervengiftung
zuvor hatte nawalni Putin und seinen
engsten Zirkel angegriffen indem er
deren Reichtum öffentlich machte
in einer Dokumentation zeigt naval nie
einen Palast am russischen Meer der den
Präsidenten gehören soll geschätzte
Baukosten über eine Milliarde Euro
na weil nie überlebt den Giftanschlag
Vladimir Putin streitet jede Beteiligung
staatlicher Stellen ab
das sind Anschuldigungen keine Beweise
es sind Anschuldigungen amerikanischer
Geheimdienste wenn sie Recht hätten ja
dann hätten unsere Geheimdienste
wirklich ein Problem meinen Sie nicht
dass wir es dann auch wirklich bis zum
Ende gebracht hätten und wir wissen ja
putin ist ein gelernter Geheimdienstler
und sein seine hauptprofession sein
Beruf besteht darin Risiken frühzeitig
zu erkennen und möglichst auszuschalten
und das bedeutet eben
einen bestimmten regierungstil der
präamt repressiv ist
2014 annektiert Russland die Krim unter
den sogenannten kleinen grünen Männchen
die damals die Halbinsel im Handstreich
besetzen sind auch wagnerkämpfer für
Putin ein Erfolg auf ganzer Linie
und wir sehen das in dieser Zeit die
Popularität des Präsidenten in der
Bevölkerung massiv gestiegen ist also
vor der Annexion der Krim waren seine
Umfragewerte bei der Frage stimmen sie
ihm zu war knapp über 60% gelegen und
dann innerhalb von 12 Monaten und 25%
Punkte nach oben gegangen auf 88%
. die Zustimmungswerte sind auch dann
noch überraschend hoch als sich der
Ukraine Krieg zur Phase entwickelt
im September 2022 verkündet Putin die
Teilmobilmachung
300.000 Reservisten sollen eingezogen
werden eine extrem unpopuläre Maßnahme
[Musik]
machen hier ist in vielen Städten
vorzeitig abgebrochen worden weil man
eben gemerkt hat das löste der
Bevölkerung eine teilweise panische
Reaktion aus die Rekrutierung derjenigen
die notwendig sind für die Kriegsführung
läuft in Russland
weiterhin vor allem entweder über Zwang
oder über attraktive kommerzielle
Angebote ich bin ziemlich sicher dass
wir auch nicht noch mal eine derartige
Mobilisierung sehen werden das kann das
Regime nicht so schnell und nicht so
aggressiv machen
doch die öffentliche Kritik richtet sich
gegen den Krieg im allgemeinen oder die
oberste Militärführung Putin selbst wird
nicht direkt herausgefordert
das ändert sich am 24 Juni 2023
im Staatsfernsehen spricht der Kreml
Herr überraschend von einem Aufstand und
von Verrätern die zu neutralisieren sein
aber natürlich ich wende mich auch an
jene die in diese kriminelle
Angelegenheit hineingezogen wurden
und das ist die erste offizielle Message
die wird im Fernsehen übertragen und sie
wird wiederholt alle 30-45 Minuten läuft
sie
Stunden später wird Putin sich auf einem
Deal einlassen die Aufständischen sollen
ungeschoren davon kommen im Gegenzug
bläst prigos
und ich denke tatsächlich dass das ein
großer großer Schockmoment war für alle
Beteiligten auch für die Elite und auch
für den Kreml zu sehen dass hier in so
einer Nacht und Nebelaktion buchstäblich
naja fast ein Putsch gelungen wäre
nach 23 Jahren Herrschaft reichen am
Ende wenige Stunden um die Illusion von
Putins Allmacht im Inneren zu zerstören
[Musik]
ich denke wir werden das als einen
Wendepunkt in Erinnerung behalten ab da
haben alle verstanden der Kaiser ist
nackt
als effektiver kompetenter Führer ist
dadurch unwiderruflich beschädigt
er hätte es kommen sehen müssen er hätte
den Krieg überhaupt nicht beginnen
dürfen
die Zustimmung für Putin ist nur
oberflächlich
aber ist das System Putin wirklich
ernsthaft gefährdet
[Musik]
wie loyal ist sein engster Zirkel noch
als pregorge ins Truppen in Rostow
einmarschieren Schweigen putinsgetreuer
auch das Militär leistet praktisch
keinen Widerstand
das Erstaunliche an diesem Staatsstreich
ist dass es so gut wie keine Kämpfe
werden dass die russische Armee und der
russische Sicherheitsapparat nicht
eingegriffen haben niemand hat sich
öffentlich an Putins Seite gestellt
die ausbleibende Reaktion der eigentlich
für die innere Sicherheit zuständigen
Angehörigen der russischen Streitkräfte
der Polizei der regionalen Eliten der
Gouverneure sagt eigentlich auch sehr
viel darüber aus wie sehr dieser Staat
und dieses Regime tatsächlich verwurzelt
ist in der Gesellschaft also man sieht
das System was darauf basiert
durch zentralistische Impulse und
Instruktion gelenkt zu werden ist
natürlich kein System was ich aus freien
Stücken wert wenn das Zentrum schweigt
und das Zentrum war selbst still und hat
nichts erklärt doch nichts angeordnet
erst als Putin vom Kreml aus das Wort
ergreift ist klar was vor sich geht
[Musik]
zur gleichen Zeit greifen
Kampfhubschrauber der Luftwaffe die
wagnertruppen auf ihrem Weg in die
Hauptstadt an
um 18 Uhr erreichen die Söldner Kassen
nur 60 km vor Moskau gelegen
zweieinhalb Stunden später bricht
brigoche in den Vormarsch ab warum
bleibt auch Wochen nach dem Aufstand
schleierhaft
während der Dreharbeiten zu diesem Film
haben wir mit gut informierten
Beobachtern gesprochen die glauben das
Geheimnis dessen was an diesem Tag
hinter den Kulissen geschah gelöst zu
haben
ich habe an diesem Tag die Aktion der
Geheimdienst in St Petersburg verfolgt
Berichten zufolge wurde das
Hauptquartier von gregorien durchsucht
dabei wurden Drogen und verschiedener
Pässe gefunden aber sie suchten auch
seine Familie im Hotel auf
hat Putin bringt Familie als Geiseln
nehmen lassen und so das Ende des
Aufstands erpresst
[Musik]